those old elections were you sure you
had a Republican who was always going to
win in a Republican district versus a
sacrificial lamb Democrat you might feel
better for five seconds if you're a
Democrat checking the box sacrificial
lamb but you didn't really have any
power
hi I'm Zack Weiss molar for recent TV
here with a Jason Olson director of
independent voice org an association of
independent voters devoted to electoral
reform in California he recently
co-authored a study on California's top
two primary system called a quiet
revolution Jason thank you very much for
talking to us oh thank you very much for
having me I appreciate it
let's start with the basics what is the
top two primary system how is it
different than how most states run their
primaries the top two systems actually
pretty simple in most states you know
the Democrats Republicans and whoever
else they get to have a particular
cannon on the ballot and in order to
participate and select that cannon you
typically have to be of that political
party unfortunately that locks out
independent voters that locks out all
kinds of different folks particularly
when you take into account
gerrymandering of districts so that most
districts are one party the difference
is under the top two nonpartisan primary
all the candidates just run on the same
ballot all the voters can just vote for
whoever they want and then the top two
vote-getters go on to a runoff style
election the fall so really it returns
the political power and the power to run
the elections it takes it away from the
parties and turns it over to voters so
the title of the study is a quiet
revolution why is this reform been
revolutionary the most obvious effect to
most people is that California is
governing again we're no longer stuck in
partisan dysfunction of government
shutdowns and budget crises the
legislature is actually functioning
together once again it's a very
different environment and that's because
our elections are competitive now in
California so when people think about
competitiveness and elections they might
think oh there's a lot more candidates
to choose from a lot of different
parties we can choose from but the
practical effect of this has been a lot
of single party races to Democrats
running against each other in a Democrat
district to Republicans running against
each other in a Republican gerrymandered
district how is that more competitive
than when you actually had some at least
some competition between a Republican
and a Democrat we've been led to believe
over the years that what competition
means is one Democrat one Republican in
the fall the challenge is that most
districts have become
single party districts whether because
they're gerrymandered or because of a
long-term demographic shift those old
elections where you sure you had a
Republican who was always going to win
in a Republican district versus a
sacrificial lamb Democrat you might feel
better for five seconds if you're a
Democrat checking the Box sacrificial
lamb but you didn't really have any
power and there was really no reason for
that Republican to come knocking on your
door talk to you now contrast that to
the current system where yes in a
Republican dominated district if I'm a
Democrat I'm going to probably get two
Republicans in the fall but rather than
just running to their base they can't do
that they're going to split their base
so now both Republicans have to go out
and figure out how do I get enough
independent voters how do I get enough
Democrats how do I get enough third
party voters to put together the kind of
electoral coalition that's actually
going to win and that's actually
empowered all voters and made the
elections much much more competitive in
these formerly one-party districts so
when you talk about competitiveness
you're talking about margin of victory
and kind of turnover incumbents getting
kicked out of office and so forth right
what what kind of numbers did you see
there specifically to delve into it a
little bit deeper elections in
California previously they were one of
the least competitive in the country
virtually a 100 percent incumbent
reelection rate that means if you I was
already in the legislature at Congress
and I could run for another term I was
virtually guaranteed to get that seat
under the old partisan system what we
found in 2012 and 2014 was it 14
incumbents lost their seats 7 of them
lost their seats to people from the same
party in one of these same party races
the other thing that we found is that
California's elections went from one of
the least competitive in the country to
the most competitive between 2012 and
2014 when you look at the district races
across California is there a case study
that really exemplifies what top-2 is
accomplished mark levine versus michael
allen now both of these are Democrats
and they're in Marin County which is a
heavily Democratic district right now in
the past Michael Allen who was actually
moved into the district he was an
incumbent he was moved in from another
district
in order to secure the seat Mark Levine
who was a San Rafael city councilman
decided to run against him and represent
the people who are actually in the
district he was in a carpetbagger being
moved in so you had this really
interesting race there where Michael
Allen with huge support from the
Democratic Party establishment placed
number one and my and Mark Levine placed
number two so then we got to the general
election Mark Levine reached out to all
voters he reached out to Republicans he
reached out to independence he reached
out to Democrats Michael Allen ran a
really partisan campaign in fact they
started to smear Levine as not a real
Democrat because he was actually talking
to Republicans and he was talking to
independents oh my gosh you know
terrible terrible thing well it turns
out Mark Levine ended up winning that
race so he defeated an incumbent with
the full backing of his political party
as an insurgent candidate in a general
election in which all voters were
allowed to participate and he did so by
reaching out to all voters so that to me
is what top-2 is absolutely all about
it's no longer appealing to a very
narrow segment of your base and taken a
vacation during the general election
because you're in a gerrymander district
and you don't have to do anything it's
about competing for all votes and
empowering voters is this kind of caving
to the idea that we're going to have
gerrymandered districts we're going to
have all these single party districts
there's no hope of any sort of inter
party competition in the future so it
the best we can do is kind of optimize
intra-party competition yeah I wouldn't
I wouldn't phrase it that way in fact I
actually I and other independents across
the country are really excited about
maybe moving to a phase of governance
that goes beyond party right where we we
leave the trappings of this kind of like
very solid Republican on this side
Democrat on this side and that's how
every issue gets frame towards something
that's that's much more open and
inclusive of everybody so is the long
game that you see this is actually
undermining the power of the major
parties and if so how would that work
yeah I don't think any of us are calling
for the elimination of political parties
but I think what we
is that the political parties have
literally taken it taken away the voters
right to run our own government what
this is really about in terms of the
long game is about the voters and the
citizens of the country taking back our
government from the control of the
political parties and what about third
parties how do they fit into the scheme
if at all are they totally locked out
now I have a long history and third
parties I was in the Reform Party in the
1990s and early 2000s third party voters
have a lot more power under the current
system the third parties themselves
continue to play I'm going to take my
ball and go home
strategy rather than engaging what they
could do for instance if their
candidates didn't make it to the second
round
they could get together and go to the
candidates and say looks we've got seven
thousand registered voters in your
district and it's two Democrats running
and we're from the Green Party and these
are the top three issues in the green
party so where do you guys stand on our
actual issues because we're going to
make an endorsement and our votes
actually matter now so they can leverage
that power and actually have real impact
on public policy debate rather than just
running a candidate that's going to get
two or three percent of the vote from a
libertarian perspective when we hear
that you know there's less partisan
bickering more legislative action it
actually kind of sends chills down our
spines term time to time because we
think oh that means more spending more
bad bills being passed are there any
bright spots for people who want to
reduce the size and scope of government
when it comes to the top two reform
absolutely it's small-l libertarians
right who often end up voting Republican
can discuss there's often not a
libertarian Party candidate running in
their district I think that there's a
lot of benefits particularly for those
kinds of folks out there so under the
new system particularly in a district
that's dominated by Republicans again
the libertarians you go to both
Republican candidates and say listen you
actually need our votes this time guess
what we've got a list of demands here's
the top three issues of libertarians in
in this district we're going to be
making an endorsement of one of the
candidates where do you guys stand on
our issues and then when that Republican
gets elected
with that coalition that includes
libertarian voters or a Democrat from a
to Democrat district gets elected with
with voters from that libertarian
coalition now they're on record they say
this is where what we're going to work
on and if they come back the next time
looking for your vote and they've done
nothing you actually have the power to
get rid of them which is something you
didn't have under the old system
Jason Olson thank you very much for
talking to us thank you very much for
having me appreciate it for recent TV
I'm Zack Weissmuller